this would have been the funnest time of
her life to have those kids running
around that house and being able to like
go and buy them toys Kanye West getting
candid about the passing of his late
mother dhunda on my next guest needs no
introduction with David Letterman but
you know she's here yes with us and
she's guiding us season 2 of the Netflix
series drops Friday and Kanye also opens
up about his bipolar disorder he was
diagnosed two years ago he says if you
don't take medication every day you can
ramp up which is when you can start
acting erratic he says it can also leave
you hospitalized quote when you're in
this state you're hyper paranoid about
everything everyone this is my
experience other people have different
experiences you feel the government is
putting chips in your head you feel
you're being recorded you feel all these
things
Kanye goes on to talk about the stigma
surrounding the disease quote this is
like a sprained brain like having a
sprained ankle and if someone has a
sprained ankle you're not going to push
on him more with us once our brain gets
to a point of springing people do
everything to make it worse I've had it
with people
blatantly treating my husband a certain
way and making him look a certain way
things do take a lighter turn on the app
though Kanye gives Dave a style makeover
letterman swag
[Music]
that's fire Kanye how do I look do I
look okay or do I look like oh my god
what's he up to like an artist that's
rest day I know I feel really good and
this is stuff even if I was not doing
this and if somebody could drive me to
the mall I'd buy this
[Music]